foreign
[Music]
art but it's also a craft I've always
been interested in history and politics
and how that informs what we do how we
think what we were everything is
interesting and informative to what
people were or War my job is to help
translate the director and the actors
vision for the character and kind of
help tell the story and also help the
audience understand who the person is
where they are in time there are the
homages to Juan Carl why in the mood for
love but also references Michelle yo the
actress she had suggested some brands
that she liked and one of them was
elisab they had graciously sent some
dresses for us to borrow the one that we
see is the one with that work the best
for the scene we did submerse a lot of
clothing in the water we needed to be
honest about what happens when things
are in the water and how do they move so
we informed the effects it wasn't VFX
informing us it was the other way around
it started out as a concept of red it
was a work in progress and it took us
about six prototypes but eventually we
narrowed it down everybody keeps on
saying it's a dress and it's not a dress
I call it a play suit and it's short the
idea was that it was Nelly she had very
little money at the time in my mind she
cobbled it together if you have good
costumes you should be able to read more
into it than just that person is wearing
a red shirt you should be able to feel
who the person is and where you are
[Music]